[MUSIC PLAYING]
GRACE-ANN BAKER: Hi, I'm
Grace-Ann Baker, product
manager for Persistent Disk.
And before we start
off, just want
to thank you all for coming--
first coming to Next.
I know you've taken enough time
to come here for three days.
And most importantly,
thank you for coming
to hear about Persistent Disk.
ANTON SUKHANOV: And
I'm Anton Sukhanov.
I'm part of Persistent
Disk engineering team.
And we also have
several other engineers
from Persistent Disk here who
will help to answer questions.
GRACE-ANN BAKER: So,
just a brief summary--
we'll talk about simplicity,
performance, snapshots--
talk a bit about
Persistent Disk & GKE,
and some recommended sessions if
you wanted to learn a bit more
about Persistent
Disk, or how it's
used as part of--
as a product on GCP,
and then open up for questions.
Generally speaking, if
you have a question,
there's a microphone in
the middle of the room.
Try to keep your questions
to the end of the session.
However, if there's something
that's just not resonating
or just doesn't connect, feel
free to just raise your hand,
and we'll try to get to you.
The session is being recorded.
So, please-- part of the
hygiene in using the microphone
is just so that for
later use they'll
be able to capture
what the question was.
And with that, I'll begin.
So on GCP we actually have
three storage offerings.
Before I go into this, how many
of you are GCP users today?
Persistent Disk users?
So it's about--
I'd say about 60% of the room.
And so-- and GCS?
Object Store?
Anyone in the room using GCS?
OK, so that's good news.
You'll have a fair sense of what
the product is, in which case
if you would like deeper
information, ask questions,
we're also going to
be around later on.
So, if you'd like to
just give me your name
and we could arrange
to talk offline after.
So on GCP right now we
have three storage options.
We have our optic
storage, and we actually
have two storage offerings that
are both for block storage,
available for Compute Engine,
our VM, or base product.
GCS is our optic storage.
It's geo redundant,
primarily used
for live and archival data--
a lot of more
streaming work cases.
For block storage,
or for GCE, we
have what's called local SSD.
And the way to think
about local SSD,
is that it is running in
the same machine as your VM,
or as the instance.
It tends to be used for
workloads that require
very ultra high performance.
However, the one caveat
is that it's [INAUDIBLE].
So, if anything should
happen to that VM,
your data is also gone.
So, the life of your
data exists just
in the construct
of that instance.
Persistent Disk,
on the other hand,
which is the other
storage offering,
is available for any VM that
you're using as part of GCE.
It is highly durable, which
means that the disk is
a standalone entity.
If the VM goes
away, or comes back,
or you would like to use
that disk of different VMs,
you can do that.
Fairly high
performance, and so this
is a product that's targeted
at enterprise applications.
Any virtualized
enterprise applications
requiring virtual
lock storage is where
you would use Persistent Disk.
So, when you're thinking
of performance-- that's
the level of performance
we're talking
about with Persistent Disk.
And just as a caveat,
this is the product
we're going to talk about today.
If you're interested,
there are lots of sessions
focused specifically on GCS.
Local SSD is being addressed in
the context of Compute Engine.
And so, if you're
interested in learning more,
I'd suggest some of the
Compute Engine sessions.
And today we're talking
about Persistent Disk, which
you'll hear me refer to as PD.
I do have some sessions
listed at the back
of the presentations.
So if anyone's interested in
some of those other sessions,
it's in the presentation.
So starting with Persistent
Disk and Two SKUs--
I think one of the key
things about GCP in general,
and specific to GCE
and Persistent Disk,
is we really try to keep it
simple for our customers.
We don't have a
large set of options
available for customers.
And the idea there, is
that rather than customers
having to really
think hard about--
what are their workloads?
What are their use cases?
And then try to map it to
different SKUs offering--
we really try to keep it
simple, as to two offerings.
And you'll see a lot
of things are just
bundled as part of
the base offering,
or these two SKUs will stretch
and fit different workloads.
So starting out with
key characteristics,
PD Standard is
really what you would
see being used for more of
our general purpose workloads.
The thing about there-- it's
good enough performance.
And when I say, good enough,
people are always like,
Grace-Ann, what is good enough?
Good enough turns
out to be good enough
for the bulk or the large swath
of enterprise applications,
that really don't need ultra
high performance that you would
see, or that's available,
with your flash drives.
And when I'm talking
performance there,
I'm talking both
latency and also IOPs.
And so, if you've got your
enterprise database that
will really need
high throughput,
high bandwidth, high latency,
then definitely PD SSD
is most likely your product.
The other thing
there is you tend
to be less price sensitive for
those types of applications.
Those are the applications
that you would run on PD SSD.
For most of your
other applications,
they do fairly well
on PD Standard.
And this is just a typical--
and I know that
in the enterprise
there really isn't any
typical applications.
And I know that
people say, well, I
show enterprise apps as PD SSD.
Truthfully, they run in
either of these columns.
Other key points, as to
just give you a sense of--
how do we differentiate
these two?
What are the key characteristics
between PD Standard and PD SSD?
You can see IOPs per gig.
And here you're seeing
a meaningful difference
between the two offerings.
For PD SSD you've
got 30 IOPs per gig,
whereas for Standard
it's just 0.75 for read
and 1.5 for write.
For things, if you
look at your max IOPs,
you're going to see for
PD Standard, for reads
it's 3k, for writes 15k.
PD SSD, on the other hand--
it's 40k read IOPs,
and 30k for write IOPs.
And An I'll just
pause for a minute
here and comment that-- that
is actually something new.
Today, at Next, one of the
things we're announcing
is the higher IOPs
availability for PD SSD.
That is available today.
For many of you who said
that you are using PD,
if you're using
Persistent Disk SSD,
you're getting that
performance level today.
Or you should be, and if
you're not, please let us know.
And last point on this,
because I know a lot of people
are probably wondering, so,
what's the big difference
according to--
that goes beyond
the characteristics
of the drives themselves.
You can see there is a big
significant price difference
between these two offerings.
OK.
So, just talking a
bit more about what
is Persistent Disk
and the key features.
So, I mentioned earlier
that it's persistent.
And that really just comes
back to this construct of,
the life of your
disk is not tied
to the life of your instance.
And so, however,
most of the time
to use your Persistent
Disk, someone
creates a VM on Compute Engine,
and with that you're also going
to create a disk to go with it.
Anything should
happen to that disk,
anything should happen to
the connectivity to the disk,
the disks lives on.
If you should then
decide that you're
going to have another
application that needs access
to that same data, just
create that new instance
and connect it to your disk,
and you're up and running.
We have this idea of
how many disks that you
can attach to a VM, and
we hear this fairly often.
And so, the number
of disks that you
can attach to any given instance
is 16 drives, or 16 disks.
And you can have both read
write and read only disks.
At any given time
you can only have
one read write disk attached
to a VM, but the number of read
only will vary.
And that's really up
for you to decide.
And here, you can also--
Another feature of the
product is, you can have--
for those read only disks--
you can have those being
read to from multiple VMs.
Also, once again,
that's up for you
to decide for your
different environment.
And on the subject
of availability,
PD is a zonal service.
And what that means is that
one of the only restrictions
around Persistent Disk,
is that it needs to live,
or it does live, in the same
zone as your VM instance.
They are highly available,
and under the covers one
of the things we do
with Persistent Disk
to drive the high
availability is
for every write there's
actually three replicas written.
Customers are, of
course, only charged
for one of those copies.
However, the way that we
deliver greater availability
to customers is this
idea of the multiple
writes being done
under the covers.
And this here is
just intended to show
that-- this whole construct
of, if you have multiple PDs,
and you happen to have those
instances in different zones,
the disks that attach
to those instances
will also exist in
those different zones.
Talk a bit about capacity,
and that the actual numbers
fill the systems.
So, the maximum PD size
right now is 64 terabytes.
One of the things we
were very interested in
is if anyone has
the need, or how big
is the need for that
number to increase.
It's one of those things that
we've been working on doing,
but priorities change.
And so, I'd love to get a signal
as to how important that is.
For most customers
we're seeing that 30--
20 to 30 --terabytes
is good enough.
We do have some
larger, but that's
something that we'd be
interested to know about.
Coming back to this--
how many disk size to a VM.
If you recall
earlier, I mentioned
that you can actually have
multiple disks attached
to a VM.
One of the constraints,
even though you
can go up to 16 disks--
the sum of those 16 disks
cannot exceed 64 terabytes.
So, you can't have
16 64 terabyte disks
attached to a VM.
And I think one
of the key things
here is this whole construct of,
do you need to stripe or not.
And this is one of
the things that's
a key differentiator for us,
is this idea that you can go up
to, have this very large
drive and not have to stripe.
So, there's a whole level
of management complexity,
or management overhead,
that you don't even
need to think about as you scale
your data set to these larger
numbers.
And then, lastly, I think
one of the other things
that the team
stresses with me is
this whole construct of being
able to hot grow your disk.
So, often you're not sure
what size disk to get.
So, you start small,
and as your needs
grow you can readily
just grow your disk
size without having to stop
and restart, or do anything
on the VM.
So, once again, just giving
you a lot of flexibility
without any downtime
in your environment.
On the subject of
encryption and security--
and this is one
of those features
we're coming back to
the point of trying
to keep the product
simple, trying
not to have a whole
bunch of bells
and whistles that people
have to think about
for their different data
sets in their environment.
With Persistent Disk, and
on the platform as a whole,
all of your data is encrypted.
And it's always on.
It's one of the core features.
And we support both--
by default it's
Google generated keys.
But for instances or customers
where they have their own keys,
we also support that.
So, it's fully integrated
with our Cloud Key MS System.
And I think one of
the other things
on the subject of security is--
because Google Cloud runs
entirely in the Google Network,
your data never leaves
the Google Network.
So, there's no concern about
being on the public internet.
And so, there's
this idea of, well,
what about data in flight.
And so, the question
is, well, it's
never leaving the
Google Network,
and it's encrypted
whilst on the network.
So, it's just a way
of-- a different way
of thinking of the product,
and of security, and the data
on the network.
OK.
ANTON SUKHANOV: Performance,
we take very seriously
on Persistent Disk.
And today, we are
proud to announce
substantial performance
increases for our PD SSD
product.
For IOPs we increased
from 25,000 to 30,000 IOPs
on writes, and 40,000 read IOPs.
And throughput increases
are even more substantial.
We go from 240
megabytes per second,
to 400 megabytes
per second writes,
and 800 megabytes
per second reads.
Also, today we are announcing a
full duplex on SSD throughput.
What does it mean?
It means that you can achieve
400 megabyte per second reads,
and 800 megabyte per second
writes at the same time.
This is not true for IOPs.
So, IOPs you still can do
either one or another limits.
But for throughput,
duplex throughput
is important for many
enterprise applications,
and we were asked many times
to provide this feature.
So, it's really
exciting to date.
Now, I want to mention that
when we talk about IOPs,
it's important to understand
that Persistent Disk is
a networking disk, which is
really cool for availability.
Because you can take
one Persistent Disk,
as Grace-Ann mentioned,
and attach it to any VM.
And you can shut down the VM.
You can keep your disks
and attach them later.
It also brings high availability
of the Persistent Disks.
But it comes with some
cost, and the cost
is a little bit
of extra latency.
Our latencies are
competitive on the market.
But we need to understand that
to get to the high IOPs limit,
your workloads should
maintain certain queue depths,
especially for these
ultra high IOPs loads.
The new increases, they
come for large VMs.
So, for VMs up to 15 cores
we keep the old limits.
But from 16 cores and up
the limits are increased,
and the maximum limits can be
achieved on 32 and higher VMs--
32 cores and higher.
Persistant Disk
Standard, at this point,
characteristics are not changed.
But I just would
like to mention again
that we offer a very competitive
price for performance
ratio for PD Standard Disc.
Two And currently it can
go to 15,000 write IOPs,
and up to 3,000 read IOPs.
And throughput is 120
megabytes per second on writes,
and 180 on reads.
So a little bit about how
we approach performance.
For us, the simplicity is
very important in our approach
to both SKUs and performance.
We want to offer
consistent performance.
So, you pay a certain
price for size.
You get IOPs.
You get throughput
with the size.
And you get consistent
performance in every zone
where Persistent
Disk is offered.
You don't need to
bother with striping,
as Grace-Ann mentioned.
And in Persistent Disk, to
get the best performance,
you can just attach one large
disk if it suits your workload.
Or, another choice, is you
can attach many small disks,
and you can attach
them to the same VM,
and you get the same
performance as large disks.
We know that some
other solutions they
require striping, which is
not a very good solution
for the customers.
So, we are happy that we
offer simplicity here.
The disk size-- we want you
to have the disk size chosen
for performance and for space.
And then if you need to
get more performance,
we have online any size for you.
And by the way,
performance is something
that we take really
seriously in PD,
and we are always
looking for feedback.
I'm sure we have
customers in the room,
and we would like to learn
more about your scenarios.
And If you think we need
to deliver more IOPs,
more throughput--
if you think our model is too
simple, We would like to talk.
GRACE-ANN BAKER: OK.
Snapshots.
And so, one of the
big requirements
we hear from enterprises,
or most of our customers,
is, so, what happens in
the event of failure?
Or, what if I want
multiple copies of my data?
How do you do that?
What do you have
available for us?
First thing we
have is snapshots.
And think of this.
This is very similar
to what most of you
are familiar with a non
param storage array.
Snapshots exist
independent of the source.
And what I mean by
that, is that snapshots
will exist in a
different zone and region
than the actual primary data.
And let me just pause for a
second about the construct
of a zone and region.
GCP is actually set up,
and it's broken down
into-- you have your geo areas.
Nested inside of
the geo areas you
have your different regions.
And then inside of the
region you have your zone--
similar to other cloud products.
I don't think anyone has
really filed a patent on how
they structure-- that overall
structure, or tearing,
of the network.
For snapshots, as I
mentioned earlier,
are for Persistent Disk.
You have your VM, and the
data associated with the VM
is sitting in a zone.
And here I talk about zone
A, just to make it simple.
And zone A, and the
VM, and the disk,
are all sitting in
region A. The top, what
it's trying to show here,
is that you have a snapshot.
And that snapshot is
actually living elsewhere
in a different region
than your primary data.
Key thing here, and
the key ask that we
get from customers is well, what
happens if zone A disappears?
We've all been
around for a while,
a zone isn't likely to
just, poof, and disappear.
But what if there's a
failure in that zone?
What if I lose that data?
Will I also lose the
copy of that data?
The answer is, no.
Under most circumstances
you shouldn't.
Because it's quite unlikely
that you're going to have a fail
that will affect both region
a and a region somewhere else
in the country.
One of the key things about
snapshots is, today, right now,
snapshots, it's totally--
it's a feature that's available
as part of Persistent Disk,
but the control is totally
within the customer.
So, the frequency--
well, first and foremost,
--if you'd like to
snapshot your data,
that's something that we
leave up to customers.
And not all customers choose
to snapshot their data.
So, let me just start with that.
And then the next thing is,
the frequency of snapshotting
is also something
that's up to customers.
The technology right
now is not intended
to be used as an alternative
to synchronous replication.
So, you know, the idea of
snapshotting every minute,
or every couple of minutes--
the system wasn't built for
that, and what will happen,
quite frankly, is that you'll
see that your snapshots take
a very long time to complete.
However, what we do see,
and where the system
is more optimized for
is snapshots daily,
snapshots every couple of
hours average during a day.
Those are the typical use cases
that we see for snapshots.
And they are primarily what
people are using it for,
is to have a backup copy, or
have a second or third copy
of a given data set.
Other big question
we often get about
is, where my snapshot stored?
And I know there's some people
that says, why does it matter?
And I know for customers
that the big thing here
is, coming back to this question
of, in the event of a failure,
does it have the same
risk as the active data?
But some customers just want
to know that regionally-- there
are some geopolitical issues
at play for some customers.
And so, the answer here is,
just it's stored in GCS.
Right now we do not
make any of the GCS APIs
available for the objects.
And so, the only
access that customers
have to these snapshots
is via Persistent Disk.
But if there are
customers that are
interested in that
level of functionality,
please ping me after, because I
would love to better understand
that use case.
And one of the key
things about snapshots
and how they are used,
is this idea of-- you
can restore a snapshot anywhere.
And so quite often, what
we see customers doing--
and just earlier today
we had a customer
who was using Persistent Disk.
And in region A--
excuse me.
And they now would
like to fire up
a different database instance
using the same data set.
They're in the
midwest, and they have
an office in the west
coast, and they'd
like to use that same data set.
And so, one of the great
use cases for snapshots,
is you take a snapshot
of the data set,
you create an instance
in that second zone,
create your Persistent
Disk in that second zone,
and at the same time, then copy
the data from your snapshot
over to that second location.
And that's one way of getting
access to that same data set
in multiple locations.
We have-- the
other use case here
is a temporal one, where
you have Persistent Disk
and you've got all your data.
You're using it this
week, and it's data
that you only use once a month.
Rather than pay for the disk
and keep it live all the time,
they'll take a
snapshot of the data.
Park it.
And a month from now they'll
create another instance,
remount the snapshot,
and use the data again.
So it's just another
way of having access
to your data in a more
temporal fashion than having
it mounted all the time.
One of the key things
about snapshots
is this idea that
it's cost efficient.
This becomes relevant,
because customers
are very cognizant of
the side of these--
you're keeping
copies of your data.
How much data are you
keeping, and a lot of it
is repetitive data.
And so, do you really need
to keep many, many copies
of the same data?
So, our snapshots are cost
efficient in the sense of,
we do both full and
incremental snapshots.
Generally the first time
that you take a snapshot,
we will do a snapshot
of the entire disk,
and that's considered
a full snapshot.
For future snapshots we
will take differentials.
And so, only the blocks
that have changed
will be kept on a
long term basis.
There are times in the
future-- so it's not just
one full and incremental
indefinitely.
We do periodically do full also.
The key point is
it's not-- if you
chose to snapshot
on a daily basis,
we're not doing full
snapshots every day.
ANTON SUKHANOV: Some
of the best practices
for performance at snapshots.
So, we think it's a good
practice to separate data
logs and the boot disks.
It makes it easier for you to
managed backups and restores.
Don't worry if your
boot disk is small.
And we know some customers,
they tell us they
create big disks for
boot and for data,
because bigger disks
have better performance.
We optimize even small
disks for good performance.
So, the striping we
mentioned, sizing
for space and performance,
resize, the queue depths.
We also recommend,
if it is possible,
to adjust to your workload to
have a more localized access.
You will get somewhat
better performance
from Persistent Disk.
For snapshots, you
can take snapshots
without stopping your workload.
I think it's a
really cool feature,
and it actually has no
effect on the workload.
So, you can keep
writing to the disk,
take snapshot at the same time.
As a matter of fact,
take multiple snapshots.
But you have to understand
that your application should
be able to restore
data at the point
where you take a snapshot.
Most databases and
file systems they can,
but it's something
to be aware of.
Test restore operations.
As we like to say,
good engineers backup,
and awesome engineers restore.
So, back up your data, restore
periodically in different zones
to make sure everything works.
About the schedule,
or snapshot schedule,
first of all making snapshots
every second may be--
it's possible, but it's
not something we recommend.
Half an hour, every half
an hour, every one hour,
is acceptable-- maybe every day.
We have customers who have
custom scripts for their needs.
Try not to schedule snapshots
of business or week days.
And the important
for snapshots--
because we do snapshots
incrementally,
your next snapshots
will be fast.
It can be-- most snapshots are
actually done within minutes.
You can make it even faster and
reduce cost if you use stream,
if it's not enabled.
Because we do not snapshot
data which is not on the disk.
GRACE-ANN BAKER: And then GKE.
This is Kubernetes,
our Container Engine.
I think the key point here--
I am not a GKE expert,
so let me start there.
The key point here is that for--
Kubernetes actually
uses-- or GKE
actually uses Persistent Disk as
the storage for the containers.
So, when you create a container,
Kubernetes cluster, the storage
or persistent volumes that are
made available to the cluster
are all Persistent Disks,
running under the cover--
is working with the GKE team.
They wanted me to
mention this here.
And if there's any questions,
or interest in this,
there are-- as I
mentioned earlier,
there's other sessions.
Or, I think there's
folks here that can
answer any of those questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]